uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh
hey
participate
so we have our 90-day challenge
objective
yeah
um
uh
[Music]
more
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
um
um
um
i keep on wanting to go to spanish when
i don't it's okay wrong it's fine it
works it helps actually
remind me how to say more than
plus
soon as i said it i remembered it
um
[Music]
all right
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's been about three months yeah yeah
that's just a good adult
so
and we're looking at known words
should we look at links
for the time being we'll stay there
circus revoir
[Music]
well i guess get your links created okay
continue
to
um
[Music]
on only the the
mini stories
um nothing against the many stories i
know we got to do what we like to do
though yeah
the results speak for themselves you're
speaking so well i'm just amazed
okay uh link's created let's look at uh
hours of listening
okay
and this
i just realized this week that this
doesn't
um like if i have an embedded youtube
video and i watch
and link i don't think that's counting
towards it i would have had to play the
audio at the top across this exactly so
this is if you want your listening hours
to count towards your statistics you
have to listen in links so if you bring
it in as a lesson from youtube
uh
if you listen to the course audio or if
you listen to your playlist that will
count if you listen to it in some other
way it won't count but you can manually
add
right but no no one ever does that but
yeah i haven't
do it but i have been listening to a lot
of music but it's just been like a
youtube video for the most part but as
you can see i've i've done some
listening
yep for sure
now let's go to your reading
okay
on
[Music]
um
trying to remember my prepositions
why do you want to say not yet
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll just finish here
i will say we can maybe finish in
english so we're starting the 90-day
challenge on the 1st of september i'm
going to participate you're going to
participate and we would like as many
people as possible to participate the
details will come out next week
as we do the first live stream
about the 90-day challenge
i will be looking at my statistics i'm
going to focus on arabic i've been doing
arabic and persian and some turkish over
the last little while i'm going to
really focus on arabic i'm going to have
a good look at my statistics i suspect
that i have a lot of yellow words links
that i've created that i don't know like
tons of them and so my big goal and as a
result
i listened to my
podcast from al jazeera and they're full
of yellow words but i don't really
understand what they're saying very well
so i really want to make a breakthrough
in my comprehension so i'm going to be
still creating you know links converting
blue words to yellow but my main
emphasis is to activate in a way or at
least to understand all my saved links
and so i will announce
uh very specific goals so you know to
the extent that you can i understand you
have a general goal to be able to speak
and understand
but i have found that if i set myself
very specific goals within link it
drives obviously all all of us want to
understand and speak i mean that's what
we want to do that's kind of the general
goal but i think you can use these sort
of very specific goals in the link
statistics to drive yourself towards
those more general goals
yeah that's so true this conversation is
enlightening me uh because
i haven't really thought of
obviously i haven't thought so much
about um putting a
numerical goal um to the language
learning but um i mean trying to
practice speaking is a really good
reality check
um
and
i think now that i heard you share your
goals regarding your statistics um i
would like to be able to i would like to
convert more links to known words
okay um
and i don't have a number necessarily
but right but it helps it helps to have
uh it's i always like in these
statistics that link you know known
words like people say oh well you know
you don't really know the word if you
can't use it and there's all kind you
can argue about whether you know
jove
has those three different words or one
word we count them as three words so you
can argue about the meaning of the but
but basically what the statistics do
i always compare it to the the dog races
ever seen these greyhounds that race in
the dog races they have a mechanical
rabbit that they chase
yeah that's why they run into it because
oh yeah on the side of the track there's
a mechanical rabbit and they all go
chasing after the mechanical rabbit and
that's what these statistics are all
about so if you chase the statistics
everything else happens so it is
worthwhile having and so at times you
think you're not doing anything and you
check your statistics yes i have i met
my goals and so i would let and i would
set the goals and i will say this again
when we start our live stream don't be
unrealistic but don't make them too easy
either
yeah i've been on a a streak and it's
addictive but i do have my my daily
links goal set to the most casual
level so it's pretty easy to make 13 new
links a day that's very easy push
yourself a little bit yeah and i should
say again i am very surprised at how
well you speak we didn't have a long
conversation but i had the impression
that you understood what i was saying
the fact that you say anton de instead
of anton is irrelevant because in a
month or two you will never make that
mistake again but you were able to
express yourself i'm very impressed and
this is strictly based on all of your
listening and reading
yeah exactly so
it's cool to see that you can convert
you know stuff that you read and listen
on link into a conversation even though
you didn't i didn't like study the
script for this conversation beforehand
naturally organic that's right okay well
shelby good luck and you'll be joining
us again for the
live streams that we do
uh for the 90 day challenge
yes i'm very excited and it's going to
be uh really fun because it'll be the
first time that we get link users
together on a zoom call where they can
all interact with each other too so yeah
we'll describe that in more detail in
the live stream but i think you have
some exciting ideas about breakout
groups and stuff like that so sure yeah
it's going to be great
okay
steve merci beaucoup
[Music]
you